j - 6 avant les élections régionales et
départementales le premier tour a lieu
dimanche pour l'île de france le ps mise
notamment sur sa proposition phare la
gratuité des transports
notre mesure phare c'est celle de la
pourquoi parce que c'est une mesure qui
est à la fois écologique est aussi bonne
pour le pouvoir d'achat
dans la situation où nous sommes
aujourd'hui il est important de
transformer notre région cette
transformation elle passe par un
changement des comportements et donc il
faut amorcer une nouvelle mobilité et
nous le ferons avec la gratuité des
transports progressive c'est important
pour justement donner une autre
impulsion à notre région